i will donate ten dollars for every pawn
you can get in the same vertical file
for the next game oh oh wow oh this this
is
this is actually an interesting
challenge okay
i'm doing it doing it so quadruple pawns
equals 40
okay i'm down for it let's do this
okay so it's all about getting quadruple
pawns
wait i have to think what opening to
play
there there is a line of the stafford
gambit
okay so the first step is to get triple
pawns
and then the next step how do i want to
do this
okay so at least i have double pawns
let's do let's do this
i don't think i've ever tried like to
intentionally get quadruple pawns
please take my bishop please because i
got a pawn cube
[Music]
this is harder than anticipated play
bishop here
a rook here okay so i want to do
something
with the things let's do this i'm trying
to win the game as i'm
also trying to get quadruple pawns
it's not easy let's try this and then
i'll queenside castle
oh yeah let's queenside castle
hey okay that's a good start
so now i need to like trade somehow
maybe this move oh i have an idea
oh it's so dirty
okay i'm only down the pawn here
so i could play this and then man that's
just not a good move though
uh or is it
it's a profitable move bishop c6
but let's let's do this properly start
with queen eight
whoa it's ciel smith with our raid
thanks ciel smith
let's give a shout out shout out see
l smith if you're just joining someone
offered me
uh ten dollars for every pawn i have on
the same file
so i'm trying to
i guess make money
this is difficult
probably this move yeah because
eventually i want this
rose is a red eric rosen is a wander
you fool you fell victim to one of the
classic blunders
oh that was very poetic kind of
this is a hilarious position my pawns
are so
square
oh there goes this pawn but i don't
really care about that pawn
i just care about quadruple pawns
oh maybe this move yeah the counter
attack
hmm
i feel like i'm spending too much time
trying to figure out just nonsense
play this
oh that doesn't work ah
okay let's try this
i'll swing over this way
okay
article 7 foreign handbook refers to
capturing the opponent's king as an
illegal move
oh interesting fascinating
wait i have two so i have adjacent
double pawns
yeah let's try
all i want is quadruple pawns
take it take a ticket ah
ah there there is a line
so i i was really hoping for takes takes
and then this and then takes
and then this and then then i could meet
me i tried
there was potential i just lost my my
rooks
it's hard to get quadruple pawns on
demand when it's not like
completely losing
[Music]
what does this say
i'll give you oh do i try one more time
i feel like i'm gonna lose so much
rating but that wasn't too bad
i was actually playing a higher rate of
player wow
that was a really interesting game
let's try one more time
i feel like i can i can do it so what i
want to do
is
let's start with e4
now the french is not a great opening
for this
uh all right let's try this
queen e2
what happened to the player name yeah so
this is zen mode
i think i explained this earlier but um
zen mode hides the player names or
ratings
the number of observers
so it's supposed to
create a more zen-like situation
okay at least i want connect four not
quite quadruple ponzo
actually don't know what the the plan is
this game
it might be hard to even get double
pawns
oh that's a good move
that's a really good move
let's play this
basically offering some trades
queen b6 is quite annoying
if you get connect six this game with
your pawns it'll donate fifty dollars
connect six wait what
oh connect six like diagonal oh so i
need pawns here and here
oh wow node is the acceptance that all
chess is suffering
all chess oh i don't know what that
means
there's not always suffering involved
how do i get connect 6
all right let's try this
oh knight d4 is coming
maybe it's not too harmful but
maybe it is as my queen's tied down to
this pawn
and this pawn is attacked well
one thing to do it's a sad square for
the knight
some kind of delayed bomb cloud over 93
king here i lose a bishop i have to play
this
this is complete trash but
i do have hope like on time
probably no hope for for double or
triple pawns
maybe a small hope for connect six
oh wait that's not even i move my h pawn
yeah okay at this point i'm just trying
to win the game and not lose more rating
okay let's fight for the c file
well i can take and play knight c5
it's probably just crushing
ouch
oh i guess i had this move still have
this move
okay staying alive queen d2
g4 coming
upon the wanted to play b3 and rook c2
not allowing that c3 good move
yeah we're not even seeing double pawns
this game
okay defending this
oh maybe this move
oh then 191 wow
this move
everything's going wrong
i guess i'll try f5
[Music]
good move
okay got i got a dirty flag that was a
messy game
wow that's a really messy
challenge play london opening and try to
get connect six and win
fifty dollars london
connect six but what is connect six
uh like on the diagonal or on just like
a rank because maybe it's easier on on
like a rank
um man
i tried i
yeah i guess it's harder than the french
to get
at least in the variation we played to
get double pawns
okay i guess i'll keep going and and try
and
like do these random challenges london
opening time
okay so london has been gone oh connect
six would
be like this
play this move it's a fun line actually
it'll allow any connect six how about
fifty dollars for diagonal and twenty
dollars for rank
okay well we'll see we'll see here is
twenty dollars for your beautiful pond
square last game
square yeah thanks for that i appreciate
it
i i i worked so hard to turn the square
into a straight line
okay so my eventual plan i guess i have
to win these pawns first
it's hard to like do these challenges
and try and actually like win the game
um especially when opponents playing
moves like that
because like f1 might be in danger
of course my opponents have no idea i'm
like even going for these
these sort of challenges okay let's
swing knight e3
so it's very possible black will take
and then
but basically if if i lose the f-pawn i
i have no more connect six possibilities
g5
huh now let's do this
so box is probably gonna take and then
okay i can
live with this so i'm only down the
exchange
one that wants to take here
let's try this
now c3 runs into takes takes so i have
to play king d1
of some weird compensation the queen is
actually really useful on each one
and box miner pieces are maybe about to
get kicked but this pawn is hanging
do i mind an end game
maybe knight h3 it's a weird move
i keep the queen i defend the pawn
some idea of this and then eventually c4
it's a big mess i'm also just wanting to
play bishop g2
how can i get better positional play oh
also sip tea
it does help to like study the games of
like classic players
like capablanca buffenik karkov
studying karpov's games was it was how i
kind of learned
learn some better piece placement
strategy
and just peace harmony actually karpov
and smizlov were the two players my
my coach had me study when i was around
probably like sixteen hundred
let's go for this taking it slowly
black might end up flagging before i
even have a chance for
any connect six shenanigans
this idea i can just go for mate against
h7
um let's play c4
kick the knights idea this and then this
i have to get the pawns rolling
it's my only chance
debating the pros and cons of these
moves
let's do this
one move away connect six
let's go connect six also
okay my wall is about to shatter oh also
triple pawns maybe
what is this oh i have a nice move okay
triple pawns
and now knight f3 and then takes and
then some mating ideas
that was a good move
and my wall is shattered oh my time too
uh let's defend that doesn't defend play
rook t1 defending the pawn
and then hey eric love your content as
always
oh thank you i don't know what to do
let's play this
c2
all i want to do oh 1983's coming
connect six
okay whoa it's 2000 bits
so close to meeting
straight queens
hey i won two i won with a second left
that was a nasty game
thanks richidan port somehow
yeah somehow black didn't take any of my
my pawns on the fourth rank
that was nice i am in the raiding range
where opponents don't know theory and i
am not good enough to
punish them when they diverge from
mainline in an opening that i am
familiar with any
tips yeah so
actually a lot of the times when the
opponent like
diverges from opening theory you can't
really like punish them right away
you just have to focus on unfollowing
principles accelerating developments
and try and build up different types of
advantages
so i mean sometimes opponents will like
blunder tactics or misplace their pieces
but um usually when they do this
okay of course you want to be tactically
alert whoa it's a giant raid
it's a really big raid from it's hafu
it's hafu thanks for reading
let's give a shout out that that name
sounds really familiar
another tip get better at playing
connect 6 in games
wins always next oh yeah so if you're
just joining
i i really appreciate the raid if you're
just joining this was my last game
some someone offered twenty dollars if i
could
if i could get pawns like this
actually offered fifty dollars for pawns
like this but that was too difficult